the marshy region in the south of france  is home to herds of white khmarg horses  one of the oldest and rarest horse  breeds in the world  since the fifteen hundreds the people of  kemarg have upheld a tradition dedicated  to caring for them  josie marie  jose guardian and margaret  hawaii the  [Music]  [Music]  for centuries there has been an  unwavering respect and devotion to the  khmar courses  they appear in artwork cave paintings  and have long been an inspiration for  the people of the region  however in recent years the population  is no longer as strong as it once was  [Music]  every day marie and other guardians feed  groom and work their horses on the land  despite all of the guardian's hard work  for them it is worth it the khmar  courses are unequivocally intertwined  with their regional identity  to uphold the tradition that keeps the  breed alive is the genesis of their  passion  [Music]  foreign  [Music]  you  [Music]  you